7 en janvier 2017 que laguiole est
inscrite au patrimoine culturel et
immatériel de la france
un passionné de niort le roberts et
doigté nos bus tu étais à l'initiative
de cette démarche
aujourd'hui toujours aussi volontaire et
encouragé par les membres très actifs du
comité de pilotage
il souhaite que la gueule martiniquaise
dans son ensemble soit inscrite au
patrimoine immatériel de l'unesco
laguiole véhicule toutes les valeurs de
l'unesco et tu te valeurs humaines on le
retrouve dans la pratique de laguiole et
pour moi c'est une consécration qu'elle
puisse arriver au top des japonais ko
n'a franchi pour que cette action soit
couronnée de succès contrairement à ce
que l'on pourrait imaginer les antilles
doivent impérativement et en urgence se
mobiliser je me suis dit j'ai investi en
écrivant au ministère un courrier de
soutien à ce projet et hier j'étais en
communication avec le président du
conseil régional de la guadeloupe par
exemple ary chalus ce pour que les
parlementaires de guadeloupe et les élus
de guadeloupe s'associe à cette démarche
et la reconnaissance effectivement de
laguiole elle-même mais des hommes qui
sont tous de laguiole depuis celui qui
l'a qui construit la yole parce qu'on a
effectivement quelque chose qui se fait
chez nous qui se construit chez nous qui
se fait dans des petits ateliers
du bord de mer donc on a des hommes qui
depuis des années il y en a même qui
sont partie des gens qui ont donné de la
valeur à cetiom et je crois que ce
serait une reconnaissance légitime un
pont cette culture martiniquaise
l'adhésion et la collaboration du plus
grand nombre est donc très importante
tout un chacun est invité à adresser un
courrier directement au ministre de la
culture il faut que ces courriers soit
donc orientée vers la transmission des
valeurs de solidarité des valeurs
d'entr'aide tout ce qu'on retrouve dans
un équipage de viol donc il s'agit bien
de la pratique de laguiole et non
forcément de laguiole festive laguiole
martiniquaise sera telle inscrite au
patrimoine immatériel de l'unesco
la décision sera connue à la fin du
premier trimestre 2009